hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the
trailer for give me shelter I literally
know nothing about this film
I just several people have told me that
you know I got to do the reaction for it
you know just several people have told
me you know you got to watch this
trailer and so I'm about to watch it for
the first time which makes me think
about something that happened recently
first off I'm not gonna come across
classy right now that people say oh dude
Ryan you should just let it go do you
know just gonna be people out there who
are douchebags like this person and then
I thought about it and I realized I
think classy has been the least of my
worries when it comes to this channel so
this trailer reaction that I'm gonna be
watching for the first time there's a
douchebag
his youtube name is Kane resurrected
it's right [ __ ] I'm talking to
you anyway
Kane decided that he should tell me my
trailer reaction to Godzilla was fake
and I was like how do I defend this you
know like it was my first time watching
it and he was like so [ __ ] persistent
and just trying to like I went to
selected psychology classes I can tell
it was fake that you planned her
reactions and it's like dude shut the
[ __ ] up it was the first time I watched
that damn trailer you just made yourself
sound like an ass the whole time I
didn't realize psychology classes also
taught you how to be a douchebag to
people anyway I've ever meet you in
person I will shake your hand and you
can suck my dick right let's do this
there's mature things in here drug
content and it's all dealing with teens
well okay I'm interested please don't
tell yourself that's Vanessa Hudgens
the meth addicts she looks like a boy a
boy I like to bang when I was eight I
was taken away from my mother when she
was arrested for drugs by the time I was
12
I was in my 10th foster home in all that
time that letter was the only thing I
ever got from you dad just can't take by
no pleasure seriously it's clear that
you are not ready to assume the
responsibility of motherhood in my home
as a shelter
damage does it hurt for you to be here
she will never let me go No
don't know what I wanted out of life
look at me now just a second chance dude
I feel like I'm being passed off as
someone's case number I want out of the
system you can go live with strangers I
don't like you family
was not expecting to be that depressed I
wasn't pretty upbeat me too this doesn't
help that I got came resurrected on my
mind